[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
as you see today we are turning the
tables
i'm doing the introduction because
my young friend martin is going to
give his testimony we finally
twisted his arm and got him
to relinquish his resistance
so martin are you ready yes let's go
let's pray heavenly father
it is always a privilege to hear
how people find you and i pray that it
will serve as an incentive for others to
seek you to
and to find you in jesus name amen
amen well martin
today you are trapped and you cannot get
away with it
any longer so you will have to tell us
about your story and how you came to
believe
what you now believe and how long ago
was it
well i grew up on a farm
my parents divorced when i was about six
years old
then we stayed with my father
and on the farm his brother my uncle
and my grandparents so we act i grew up
in this
very loving family on the farm
and we had a good relationship with my
mother as well
and we are never
actually at when i was small young
we never went to church
we were my grandparents were believers
especially my grandmother but my
grandfather
and my father and my uncle were not
church going they had their reasons
and my mother was quite religious
she was the one that continually
when we went to visit her she would take
us to church
or she would always give us nice bible
songs or buy us books that we can study
the biblical
stories and so on and when i was about
10 years old my mother started
coming through to where we were on the
farm and took us then
that we could go every sunday to church
we went to different churches
she was not in the she was in the more
charismatic churches
and so we went to that and then
eventually my father said no
we should attend the catechism classes
of the presbyterian churches in
afrikaans the
here church and
the school had a hostel and the hostel
children also went
they had cloth this catechism classes
and that was during the week so we
started attending those
because my father and them never went to
church on sundays
you were conservative but your father
never went to church
no my father never drank or smoked or
anything
did he speak religion in the home at all
no
no no so he just had good moral values
but he wasn't a church-going man yes
he was a strict man when we grow up
but we he was what he when he talked
we listened we didn't get
hidings that much because
i can remember probably i think twice or
three times
that he actually hit us yeah
the rest of the time we actually obeyed
when he was talking and he let us
well because we were three
brothers there was a lot of fighting
going on
and he just let us go until it got to a
such a stage that
maybe he saw okay he has to say
something that he would have
just said you must either rather love
each other
other than fight the whole time
something like that so we
it was a very loving environment that we
grew up in
and when i say conservative it's like
uh not in fashion that type of
thing we went to school i used to
wear clothes that you could see i'm a
farm boy
in south africa i don't know if it's
other countries as well you call it
safari parker
so it's a special little suit yeah yes
and i would have wore that that was
actually our school uniform up until i
was about
i think 10 years old and then also after
that
i wore long socks and stuff
like when the children so my i wasn't
very we weren't very uh worried about
fashion
if if i can if i express myself
correctly
and then also when i got to high school
cd players actually came out so and i
was
getting very big into music i loved
listening to music
and that's also started another love
that we'll get to
on later music played a big role in my
life
there was especially through high school
and i'm sure
a lot of people can resonate with that
i even apply memories to the types of
songs that were at that stage and what
was your favorite genre
i had a very big range
from classical and opera to
at i i was quite
conservative up until the stage
i was very conservative i never used to
listen to rock music
or to heavy metals that type of things
but that wasn't when i was younger
but in about middle high school 15
16 years old i didn't as much listen to
rock music but i started listening to a
lot of
techno type of music
i also got to be religious
because we were like i said earlier we
were going
to church on sundays and we had
catechism classes on tuesdays and then
we also started going to youth fests
me and my friends and i enjoyed it very
much but this was there was this
dual life almost there was the
there's a religious life that i and very
conservative
and then i also started experimenting
like for instance with alcohol
at 15 16 years old but i didn't drink
that much it was just every now and then
we would have a party or so
then me and my friend
we decided no we wanted to be rich
and we looked at some jobs that were
available and that people made a lot of
money in
so we decided okay we'll become
chartered accountants
that looked good and we i really enjoyed
accounting and so on things didn't
actually work out as we planned and my
friend went on to
the university of in
pretoria and i had to
go and work and study through
unisa that's a distant learning
university
learning university and then my life
changed drastically because i wasn't in
the restricted and conservative
milieu of how i grew up
and it was quite easy to get
alcohol and parties was nice and i was
also
always an outgoing person i i loved
having parties even though we didn't
always and in school
like i said we started having parties
dance parties when i was 10 years old
already me and my friends
i love dancing so we would have no
not the dancing like most people are
probably used to but
if you go like the typical long arm
dancers yes
you know i don't know if the viewers
will always everybody know it it's not
he's done the standing and yeah
it's going around and dancing perhaps i
must just tell
the viewers that you grew up in a very
afrikaans environment
and english is not your first language
no
that's why i'm struggling sorry and that
doesn't matter
we went the story and also you grew up
in that culture
now i never grew up in that culture i
grew up in a very german or a very
english orientated culture and not in an
afrikaans culture so the type of dancing
that you're referring to the first time
i was confronted with that kind of
dancing because when i got to the
university
i went to an african university
and i thought what is this
i was you know more in the
rock and roll scene and
the music i listened to was moody blues
and all of those well the moody blues
were my favorites but i didn't mind
things like
the rolling stones i was never a beetle
fan or anything like that but
uh more sort of the spiritual
weird music which is actually
you know very demonic yeah and then i
got to university and they had this
long arm dancing and you know my feet
just
wouldn't do anything like that so this
is what you grew up with i know exactly
what you're talking about
it's like bond dancing yeah you can
actually call it yeah it's like a kind
of bike
dancing and we always went to that so
that's how i grew up and i
when now when after i got to
live in the city and at all this freedom
the dancing changed a bit
because now the scenery changed and i
started going to clubs and
at this stage i was drinking uh every
weekend
we were having parties every weekend and
so on
this is now just after school so
needless to say my studying also
took a little bit longer than normal and
it should have yes
three-year course gotten to a well
let's just say i could always be
considered as a career student at that
stage
but in the back of my mind
i still i was still
religious i had a love for
but my life didn't show it at all
and then that was up until about 2000
oh let's say that was the first three
years
of after school and then it
even got a little bit worse because the
clubs that i used to go to i was
just around and we were having a good
time
but then i started
to go to like
rave parties
and i was i really like i mentioned
earlier
i already started liking the techno type
music when i was very young about 12
years old
13 years old and now
with the type of music i really enjoyed
that type of music so it became a big
part of my life
did you partake in the drug scene there
yeah well
it comes with the whole it comes with a
package that comes with it
you know there's a problem with it
because if you mention the word drugs it
sounds
oh but when you when you're there
you never talk about it like drugs
there's no not that stigma to it
and then all of a sudden it's not that
bad
if you understand i'm not i'm not saying
it's not bad
but when you're there it's totally
different and we had
i can say i we enjoyed our our time our
life
or maybe we thought we we enjoyed it
the reason being you never had any
worries
that's that's actually one of the mottos
that
there was two there were two mottos that
we went by
music is my life and no worries
because it was weekend to weekend
you had friday evening you had a
you knock off work
half past 10 at the evening the party
starts at the club
you go right through club closes
probably at seven o'clock the next
morning then you go back home you
continue your partying
saturday evening maybe if you're tired
you go to sleep otherwise sunday morning
you go so you go right through
till then and then you recoup
up until tuesday so the first two days
at work is not that great for the boss
but he never knew it and then
by thursday friday you're back at it
again
that was my life for about
five years then i met a girl
who knocked
my feet out from under here yes
and i actually met her on on the on a
beach new year's party
she was the friend of my best friend's
sister and we had a good time but they
nothing nothing materialized no nothing
materialized
that was the like i said december
the next year she actually
invited me out of the blue to go to her
school farewell so i went
but nothing nothing materialized again
so the next year she asked me to
maybe but at this stage i was i must
maybe
just mention this i was a dj
so weekends you were a dj yes well
but now i have to qualify this because i
was a dj
in the barn dancings scene
but i was also a dj in the trance techno
rave scene so she didn't know
that part she knew i was
a dj for the barn dancing she invited me
to play for her sister's 21st birthday
and i decided okay but this time
she's not going to get away so i asked
my brother to come and help
so he could do the music and i could
sort this thing out that it doesn't
slip out slip out from under you yes
again
and then she actually became my wife
three years later
but in between when now she re
uh learned that i was also this trans
techno
dj and she actually loved the music
and so we went we had a
wonderful partying life for the first
three years that we were dating
and then we got married and it still
continued
and at about 2009
i was drinking also heavily at this
stage um
and when i was drinking i became a
person that's
uncontrollable and
in 2009 there were these
mighty men conferences
[Music]
and that little
voice voice in the back said
you should go so i said to my wife okay
i'm gonna go let's see i think i must
get my life back on track
so i went but i went to my own actually
at this stage what happened was
when i met my wife her parents
and she they went to church on sundays
so i started attending a little bit
church more
on those days and then eventually when
we got married
we've got married in a church which is
the reformed church
and that led up to where i had to
decide i i had to get my relationship
back
with god with jesus with god so the next
year
i said i went again to one of these this
conferences
and i took some of my friends and family
with
so when we got back from this second
time the meeting that next year
we decided we're going to start a church
group our own church
group me and my wife were going to
church on sundays
at the stage already we went to a
non-denominational church
charismatic and then on wednesdays we
had this group
that got together so at these meetings
on wednesdays we were watching at quite
a variety of material
on conspiracies on the sabbath
on who the antichrist is and
so on and i remember
we had one dvd
that handled the sabbath
and i was quite convinced and i said to
my wife
that this is very good material and so
if
it should be the saturday i don't have a
problem with it
if the bible says so then that's
that's the way it should be along with
this dvd and material that we saw about
the sabbath there was
also another ministry called authority
in christ ministry
and they had a dvd on the 10
commandments that were
still applicable so we actually studied
this one
but this tv this ministry said that
although
the sabbath is on the saturday
you don't need to adhere to it strictly
you can still go to church on sundays
worship on sunday or any day for that
matter
but as far as it's in your
capacity you can keep the sabbath
and refrain from work do it make it an
enjoyable day
so this is the route that we actually
started to follow a little bit more
i actually took the sabbath dvd
one sunday with to my pastor and handed
it to him and he said to me
um is it from the seventh adventist i
said i don't know
but the material is very good i would
like you
to tell me what you think about it and
he said ah
no it's if it's on the sabbath we can
worship on any day
and so we left it there that was in
2010.
fast forward four years me and my wife
were living on the farm again in the
meantime
my uncle my dad's brother
and his family started going to church
with me and my
wife on sundays at this charismatic
church
but now there was also a family friend
that started having bible studies with
my uncle
and they invited me and my wife
to do these bible studies with them
but they told us that this
family friend was in seventh-day
adventist
so i said to them look the seven of the
adventists
have got they say that the saturday's
the sabbath which
i totally agree with but that's
as far as it goes the only other thing
that they want is to get you into their
church
so i i'm not interested so
they nagged me for a few months
in the meanwhile i started studying
to disprove everything that the seventh
adventist church
says except for the sabbath
and also there interpretation
of the sabbath i also wanted to debunk
so i really started digging even
went to the pastor of our church
and discussed some of it with him and he
gave me some answers
and so i started to build up quite a
knowledge base of how to counteract
adventist doctrine yes i actually still
have a notebook
where i've written all of this down
so we were ready
to go and have these bible studies and
you were going to be the adversary
now i must just add that
i wasn't always a very
calm person
what do you mean past tense
as far as i know you're still not a very
calm person
now i had a very bad temper
a feisty temper well it wasn't a
controlled one
let's put it like that and i
enjoyed getting into a
argument so everybody was
on pins and needles for this first bible
study that we were going to get together
but the lord prepared my whole life me
for this first bible study
and that i only realized after it
afterwards later
because everywhere there was some point
in my life and in our studies up till
then
that he touched on in that first bible
study only one bible study
and the main point was when he started
to show us
in daniel where the antichrist was
like i mentioned we were already
studying a lot of these material but it
was from different
different sources sources and now it
started
to get together here and it made sense
so that's why i couldn't argue actually
we was agreeing
on a lot of things
and that made me think and so we said
okay
we'll come back for the next bible study
but i think if i remember correctly on
the
that evening he the family friend
invited us to a seminar that would be
presented
by an ex-catholic because he now saw
that
i really found this bible study
interesting
so he invited us to this but we weren't
interested at all now just to backtrack
a little bit
when we add that group
that we gathered and we watch all this
that material
there was one dvd that i watched and it
was on my computer actually and i showed
it to
almost everybody that i came in contact
with
was a dvd by the name of
islamic connection and i was watching
this dvd
quite often showing it to everybody and
then i decided after this first bible
study
now i have to show this dvd to my uncle
and his family so we went the sunday
to our church and lo and behold
the sermon was
about the laws in the bible
and how it has been nailed to the cross
i was very optimistic
and thought now i had a lot of
ammunition
to in the second bible study
debunk everything that they they want so
you now have the weapons and now off you
went
i even went to the pastor after the
sermon
after and asked him if the ten
commandments
also were part of these laws
nailed to the cross and he said
absolutely
and so we got back from church we
watched
the islamic connection dvd and i was
intrigued about it again and i was
fired up we have to study more on the
subject
and the monday evening
that was a sunday the monday evening we
got back from work
me and my wife we were lying in bed and
i was interested
in finding out more about who this
person was
that presented this lecture
and i was on google and i saw wait a
minute this guy is a
south african i thought he was american
and i saw his name is walter fight
i said okay and suddenly
something told me to ask this family
friend who was doing the bible studies
who this person was that was going to
give
the lecture at the church
so i asked my wife what's up his wife
and ask oscar and oscar and so he came
back now it's while to fight
and i said no we have to go we'll be
there next
the next evening and we were working
about 145 kilometers from where this
venue
was and it was peak traffic we worked
until quarter past five the evenings
and the lectures started at seven
o'clock
and this was already the second night
the tuesday because the monday
the lectures already started so we were
driving on the
tuesday and as we got
to about 60 kilometers from the venue
it was already way past seven so we
decided
this is not going to work so we wanted
to turn around and just as we
started to turn around the phone rang
the
family friend phones said
where are we we turning around we are
too late he said no no no come
we i'm just ahead of you i'm also late
now my wife wasn't very happy because
she was already
not too keen to go anymore because it's
late and everything
it was winter so we decided okay let's
do it
drove through but we got there at about
quarter past eight
so we just caught about
a half an hour of the first lecture but
in that first lecture all the questions
that we had
for that evening were answered
so we decided okay we'll come back for
the next one the next evening
we drove about 10 kilometers from work
here the car's overeating this
was not at all
something that should happen it's
unusual and i said to my wife
it looks like something's trying to
prohibit us from
going to these lectures we'll drive this
car
through put in some water and we would
say
we'll drive it and the lord will have to
to help us on this one again
arrived about 20 minutes before the
lecture was passed got the answers we
needed
next evening drove
on the highway now we're trying to get a
quicker route on the highway
at the toll gate don't want to take my
card
we had to do a u-turn on the highway so
every night something was trying to pro
vent us from getting there and we
realized this
and eventually we went to all the
lectures
and the friday evening when we arrived
this is the first evening we arrived on
time
it's a beautiful night or it was
the sun's sun was setting we were early
because we got off earlier from work and
everything
and now my wife doesn't want to get out
of the car
so i said what's going on now
no she said i'm not getting out of this
car
it's it's the sun is setting
it's sabbath and i said now what's the
problem then
she said no if we want to accept this we
can't
our life has is going to change we won't
be able to
party anymore we won't be able to have
all this brides and
friends and all this i'm not getting out
so i'm sitting there and saying
but isn't this worldly things
eventually we got out of the car
so she finally got out she got out and
she also said
look at these people they look so happy
i don't want to get out of this car and
i said to her
let's go in there that maybe this is the
holy spirit working
and the next day was the sabbath the
last lecture
and we were driving through again so we
were living like i said we were living
145 kilometers this is 300 kilometers a
day
that we were driving though every night
and every day
there was one issue that was still
bugging me
and that was what happens to you
after you die and i said to my wife okay
you
you drive i i'm going to
just read a little bit bible and i came
to john
14. i don't know this is this is how the
holy spirit
leads and it says
i go to prepare a place for you
and when i go i'll come back i'll come
back again yeah
to take you where i am
and i read it and i read it and i read
it and i said
say to my wife what does this tell you
and i read it to her
and she was driving said that's it
well that says to me you can't go to
heaven right after you die
and i said that's exactly what it's
saying to me
and that settled that part for me maybe
some people have a lot of different
things to throw at you but that settled
it for me at that stage
and so that started our journey that was
in
in the winter of 2015.
now you attended a charismatic church
did you speak in tongues
no but what happened there
around pentecost they always have a week
of bible studies that you can do to
learn
the gift of the spirit
and we attended that we just
never got the gift
of speaking in tongues and so this
bothered us a little bit
but they said okay now you must just
have pick up your relationship
and do deeper study
pray pray and you will receive it
and when did you find out that
it could actually be a problematic
subject
only when we started studying the
fundamental beliefs of the church
and also i went through total onslaught
that's why like i mentioned in the
previous what's up prof
that i've got a lot of sympathy for
people
that speak in tongues because i grew up
in this
church my whole life and um
i think it it's quite difficult for them
to realize
that it the the way they think this gift
is given by the holy spirit
when it's not so it can be hard
but from what we've gone through
look we had to change every single view
that we had
about everything but you have a choice
and you don't just do it blindly we
never did
any of the choices that we blindly it
sounds now they are okay
we went to these four or five meetings
um that you held and whoop
the light went on it wasn't that easy i
only mentioned
the questions that i had for that
evening were
answered not all questions it took
a lot of deep bible study and i never
studied
then this is also important to know
as soon as we finished the seminar
i didn't go and take
or both of us didn't go and take dvds
and study them we went to the bible
i really started studying all the
the fundamental beliefs of the seventh
adventist church for myself
in the bible i didn't use
other preachers to tell me what it said
especially i i remember very clearly
the 70 weeks prophecy i studied it and
then
in every because it by it bugged me okay
but the calendar has changed so how can
it be still a prophecy if you use
the julian or the jewish calendar and
all of
these different calendars and i had to
study out for myself and
every time you come to the same
conclusion and that
made me a hundred so that's why when
somebody wants to
argue on the 70 weeks
it's not about somebody else telling me
i
really studied it out for myself in the
bible and that made a big difference
because the bible started to come alive
a lot more than it used to in my whole
life so you say that you were
very fond of your partying and you were
very fond of your drinking
and your wife realized that if you
continue down this
road something's going to give so the
holy spirit was already telling you
there's something wrong with this
lifestyle
oh yeah definitely so when did you
finally decide that
your lifestyle has to change
the lord also prepared me in
a way for everything that was about to
come unto us
when we were hit with this truths of the
bible
i made a promise to god that i would
stop
drinking if he would help me
secure a job because it wasn't going
very well with us
at that stage we came out of a bad
business
transactions and within a week
i had three interviews and i secured
anyone i could choose between three
different jobs so you had three
interviews
and you chose the one that you wanted
and you thank god and you stopped
drinking right
i thank god but i didn't stop drinking
and it wasn't that was in august
the next year january
i felt sick very sick
and this was right in between where i
didn't have any medical insurance
and i thought i was going to die
and eventually it turned out because i
went to doctors
and they said no i've got bad kidney
infection and i've got
bad urine track infection and all
this type of things and they gave him
medicine
and antibiotics it didn't get better
eventually it came out that i had
very bad kidney stones that were
blocking and everything in it
okay so a long story short i had to get
surgery in the end
and while i was recovering
i realized maybe
i should now stop maybe this
was just the lord's way of telling me
you had your chance don't blow it
okay so was this before the lectures
that you attended
so you were already on the road and
but your diet did that have to change
yes
amazingly what happened was
i couldn't drink any coffee
any caffeine for that matter any energy
drinks
as soon as i drank anything like that my
kidney would kill me
the same with a lot of these things
alcohol
forget it i actually okay what happened
was
i i decided okay if i
could remember correctly i think i made
the deal with god that i'd
only drink red wine
no other alcohol the worst one
and whenever i drank that ah this kidney
would kill me
anything that was not
helpful or that in the least so
eventually i
started drinking uh decaf coffee and
after about two months even the
decaffeinated coffees
my kidney would kill me i couldn't sleep
at night
and whenever i didn't there was no
i didn't have any problem and so
this started but another thing that
happened in that same time i used to
play tv games since the first tv games
game on the market
we had tv games right from i was about
10 years old
right through till
at that time and i was
sick and then whenever i had a fever
most of the time because of this kidney
and whenever i felt a little bit better
i would go sit and play some tv games
yeah within minutes
i wanted to die and eventually i started
realizing i can't play these tv games
and i actually went to my cousin
i remember it very vividly and i said to
them we'll have to sell all our tv games
we can't play this nonsense anymore
well every all these violent tv games
you know like
shooting games so you think it's because
of your adrenaline rush that you have
this kidney pain or whatever i had no
idea but because we were going to church
and all this
i thought this was a message from god
telling us get rid of this nonsense
so that prepared me
and when we started doing these bibles
and this was all before
we were doing any of these bible studies
now we have to get you a very important
part
alan white that must have been a bone of
contention
it was interesting i had
a discussion with somebody and they were
telling me
ah when we were speaking about
the saturday sabbath and the adventist
church and we want to become they said
all they do is they they worship alan
white
and i can clearly remember i said who's
ellen white
i don't know who this person is and they
said no
don't worry you'll see the it's all her
doctrines that the church follow
and that's what it's based upon
i said okay but i nothing from what i've
studied
the 70 weeks not one of these studies
have i
ever heard of her and i got all the
things that i studied out of the bible
all the answers the state of the dead
all of this
100 and it's not that i watched sermons
i did the bible study on my own and i so
this was not i couldn't understand what
was going on
and so the alan white issue was a bit
problematic for me because i didn't
study any of her materials and then
i asked the family friend and he also
didn't actually study any of
her materials and like i said previously
none of the decisions that i made or
anything that
i studied and i any of her material
studied all the things that i got out of
the bible
and eventually i started reading
one or two other books
and the race is history i will encourage
any person that has a beef with ellen
white
to read one of her books absolutely pick
up
desire of ages pick up the great
controversy
pick up patreons and profits and read it
and after you've read it make your
decision then
she doesn't dictate the bible the bible
dictates what she says
i and i've said it time and again
because there's a lot of contention
about
her if you have a contention with her
you haven't read one of her books
don't go and read a statement here in a
statement there and something that
somebody else
tells you and oh but she's got a obelisk
on a
grave i'm sorry and the
and besides the drinking and all of that
the rest of the lifestyle issue
after we the lord must have been
very prevalent in helping us in this
whole thing because it just
fell away it just fell away but it was
hard
because friendships got ruined
because the first time we got
baptized in november and we usually
i was the one organizing the new new
year's parties
and this specific year we didn't even go
to one
and everybody was asking us where we
why aren't we coming and everything and
we say and i
had to straight up say i see so that put
an
end to that little celebration you know
this whole issue of celebration is
such a bone of contention
i mean it's not just the new year that
falls away
there are other festivals that
christianity
keeps you know like christmas
and easter and easter bunnies and all
of this stuff and uh what was your
reaction towards
all of that christmas was a big thing in
our family
we were we were quite a a knit family
and
my wife's family as well so christmas is
still a big issue there um
yes when i was younger i used to
be actually a christmas father
i used to dress up i used to dress up
since i was
i think i was about 15 years old i put
up with decorating myself and i i loved
playing christmas father actually
we already studied that in our
home group and saw
that that is totally against what the
bible actually teaches
yeah it's a pagan festival pagan
festival
everything about that is pagan and i
also watched there's a very
um good sermon you'd a lecture you did
on that one
in total onslaught i'll put up with one
of those those links
but there's a lot of good material you
can study on it
so we were never
celebrating christmas
at that stage anymore so yeah christmas
was no longer an issue easter no longer
an issue
it's not that we don't recognize that
god
came to this earth for us but not on
that particular day of course exactly
now obviously once you start making
decisions like this
it causes a lot of debate in the family
right
and not everybody was probably
overly charmed that you started
keeping the sabbath and
changing your views on on health and
death and all of these issues
so how did the family the rest of the
family take take this
well it was really a bone of contention
and um up until the point it still is
we out of the our family
on um that uncle that i that
we had the bible study with him and his
wife and his two children
eventually along with me and my wife got
baptized on the same day
into the seventh day adventist church
but the rest of the family
they some of them probably still think
we're mad
not and i have a lot of discussions with
him
and it's something that somebody have to
make up for themselves
my advice is
do the study for yourself
don't listen to what your preacher
or your anybody
that you trust even say about
anything of these doctrines or studying
and i think that's a good point to
reassert again
the word of god is written not
only for a certain class yeah that is
why there was such a were such a war
over the word of god and the reformation
made it it its task to put the word of
god
into every hand
so that everybody would have access to
it
and even when the people were illiterate
they tied the bibles to the pulpits so
that nobody would steal them
and they would have readers to read the
scripture
in those early days the bible
is the great handbook
of truth and it is the bible that must
say what is right
and what is wrong and
this is what also eventually convinced
me
prophecy is the one that convinced me
that the bible
must be a supernatural book because how
do you write history in advance
then the rest was more difficult you
know i was an evolutionist
but in the final analysis once
you develop a trust in the word of god
all the questions that you have get
answered
one by one and once you start believing
the bible
and then finding the evidence to
corroborate the bible
then the bible becomes very precious
and the bible then becomes the great
cleaver
yes everything that you
get thrown at you or that you have
whatever you go through that
your answer must come from the word of
god you cannot say so and so said
no you cannot even say ellen white said
no
because who's alan white who is ellen
white you can only say the bible said
yes now once you've established that
what ellen white says he's in perfect
harmony with what the bible says then
you can start quoting that as well
exactly but you start off with the bible
and i'm glad you said that is where
your basis started with everything
every time i read ellen white
i still go you you'll whenever you read
a book of hers
she the whole time quotes the bible yes
so
keep your bible with you next to you
in fact once you start reading her and
you read the verse in the bible again it
just
jumps out at you and has so many new
dimensions to it
that uh it is like a magnifying glass
right
so yes i'm convinced as you are that the
bible is the standard
for everything in life and the bible
is the ultimate standard of truth
and where the world differs from the
bible
it's not the bible that's in error it's
the world that hasn't
grasped the length and the depth and the
breadth
of what is written there that's true
and just to make it clear
not one of the decisions that we had to
make
was easy and
ridicule on every side i mean your whole
world turns
upside down and
people think that it's just a
phase or maybe a passing
passing let me make it
very clear
without god there's no way you'll do
those changes
no you won't it has to be
the help of the holy spirit
changing you from the inside along with
your willingness
to be changed yes that's what it's all
about
and that's also important because
when we eventually were baptized and
became adventists and
started this walk it's also not
easy inside of the church
we really you you it's the
onslaught of the devil
is huge
it says in the spirit of prophecy there
will never come a time
when the hellish shadow of satan is not
cast thought your path yeah
now martin you attended some of my
lectures as you said
but there were many people in those
lectures so i never really
noticed you or knew you after that
and the first time i saw you again
was when you suddenly were at
amazing discoveries now that's a long
story that
i don't think you we have time to go
into
and it's very fascinating to me
that not having really known this young
man at all
suddenly we were thrown into a position
where he's sitting right next to me here
yeah didn't know him from a bar of soap
didn't know how he thinks what he does
and uh i wasn't i wasn't in any way
involved in any of this
no it wasn't planned no nothing was
planned then all of a sudden
the lockdown came and in that period
with all these
things happening and nobody can move we
were sort of
moved into a closer walk together
and here you are and we are both
talking about these issues and what is
amazing to me
i never ever gave a personal bible study
to you and yet
whether it is a question of lifestyle
whether it is a question of doctrine
whether it is a question of the spirit
of prophecy
or any other theological issue
i find it amazing that god
can so arrange the
circumstances and the minds of people
that even though we are totally
different people
we have exactly the same faith
exactly the same beliefs exactly the
same goals
and that is not humanly
possible that
that is how i understand when god said
jesus said that we may be one yes like
him in the father are one that doesn't
mean
that our personalities are the same that
doesn't mean that our personalities
merge
or anything like that now
you were telling me about your wife that
said she doesn't want to get out of that
car
let's just end with that how did she
eventually come around to
accepting everything because when i look
at her
i see the exact same wavelength
how did that come about also
studying the bible and what happened was
she also like me got a certain verse
that opened up a lot of her
understanding on this
where i didn't have so much a problem
about the sabbath
but more on the state of the dead
she was a little bit more
stuck on the on the sabbath and she had
a verse 1 john
2 verse 7 that says it's not a
new commandment that i give to you but
an old commandment that you had from the
beginning
and that just opened the whole
issue of issue and she accepted it and
embraced it and
so god works with the
individual mind i didn't have
any anything to do with her
making a choice and the same happened to
me
and in many many instances my wife
was actually ahead of me on many issues
where i was perhaps ahead on other
issues
and eventually they dovetail and i still
remember in
our life that the parents-in-law
accused her of being indoctrinated by me
yes we had well they never said it
with to us but i could get the the vibe
yeah that they were thinking
i'm influencing her yes and that's why
sometimes i always say to her just go
and visit or
tell and tell people your story that
they don't think i was absolutely the
one that
influenced you well there was an
occasion where my wife
by circumstances went to my
parents-in-law
for a week without me yeah
and i mean there was quite a distance
between us and
they grilled their and hammered this was
their great
opportunity and to their
utter surprise they realized that
this was not my faith this was her faith
and she could not be moved
so when the holy spirit works
he works through the word of god and the
rest
comes with the package and eventually if
it's all in harmony
and you incorporate it in your life it's
very liberating
well thank you for your story i think we
must thank god
that he still works with hearts and
minds
wherever you are in the world and the
great standard is this book
this book the holy word of god
and this is the great standard whereby
all
issues must be judged shall we close in
prayer
thank you heavenly father
once again we want to thank you
for calling people to the throne of
grace
what a privilege to know that we who are
so undeserving
and as all humanity is in the same boat
we can all come to this point of
realization that our salvation lies
outside of us and that the god
who became a man in order to pay the
price for us
has never changed he is the same
yesterday
today and forever and his gospel
of salvation has never changed
thank you for raising up
a movement that sets these
doctrinal issues in right settings
and harmonize them with the entire
history of humanity and the word of god
bless the listeners bless each and every
one of us
as we study the word to come into unity
of the spirit is my prayer in jesus name
amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears click
again to get notifications
to watch the next video click here
thank you